just what is a blunder in chess blunders
are moves so bad that you immediately
smack your forehead and wonder what the
heck was I even thinking losing a piece
for nothing not capturing one of your
opponent's free pieces or allowing
yourself to be checkmated on the next
turn blunders come in all shapes and
sizes and we've all made them they're
just part of the game anybody can make a
blunder even the world's very best
Magnus Carlson yes that Magnus Carlson
once played this move his opponent
Hikaru Nakamura just took the free
Bishop where it stood so while we can't
get rid of blunders completely we can
reduce them in our games for example
after you've identified the move you
want to play make one last blunder check
to look only for the obvious problems
with that move so don't fret the next
time you make a blunder just learn from
it and try to avoid the same mistake in
the future